[Música]
el presidente de Siria lasad asiste hoy
por primera vez en 12 años a una cumbre
de la liga árabe en Arabia Saudita país
que una vez respaldó a los grupos que
intentaron derrocar al mandatario en
medio de la guerra Siria había sido
suspendida por su papel represivo en las
protestas que iniciaron en 2011 Entonces
es el fin del aislamiento de Siria en la
región para responder a esta pregunta
saludamos en Madrid a Marta González
ella es analista política especialista
en geopolítica y además es periodista y
politóloga Señora González bienvenida a
directo a América
Hola buenos días Muchas gracias
podríamos decir entonces que con este
encuentro sería pone fin de manera
oficial al aislamiento al que estaba
sometido
podemos decir que sí
la región de oriente medio está viviendo
una situación de políticas de
acercamiento y una diplomacia muy activa
en unas relaciones que han sido muy
cambiantes a lo largo de estos años
tiene dos interpretaciones
desde el punto de vista de Irán el hecho
de que se reconozca otra vez a basada la
SAT y se le vuelva a recibir en la liga
árabe es un triunfo para para lo que
ellos consideran el el eje de la
resistencia para Arabia saudí es un
momento de distanciamiento en un momento
en el que las relaciones con Irán han
vuelto a
volver otra vez al ámbito diplomático y
puede haber una distensión en la parte
del conflicto que mantiene Arabia saudí
con Irán respecto de y en cualquier
lugar yo creo que es el momento en el
que ambas partes tanto en lados uní como
el lado de la región reconocen que la
política de Estados Unidos respecto del
aislamiento de Siria y el aislamiento de
base a las app no ha sido no ha sido
fructífero y por lo tanto hay que buscar
una salida diplomática a un hecho
consumado como es el mantenimiento de
basar al azar en el poder ahora a qué se
debe este impulso a los Estados árabes
que algún día o un día se convirtieron
en antiasat y ahora de repente se mueven
a [__] de nuevo a Siri Hay algún tipo
de interés de por medio
Bueno estamos viendo que la Guerra Fría
que mantiene Irán y Arabia saudí por por
el liderazgo de la región se ha
trasladado de alguna manera la guerra a
la Guerra Fría o ha trascendido a la
Guerra Fría regional e internacional que
también mantiene en Estados Unidos y
china en la región en la Guerra de
Ucrania puesto de manifiesto que Estados
Unidos tiene cada vez menos presencia en
la región pero también por otro lado que
los actores regionales como Arabia saudí
o Irán no tienen ningún problema a la
hora de establecer
alternativas a Estados Unidos con
relaciones alternativas con Estados
Unidos precisamente manteniendo
relaciones con con China o con o con
Rusia de todas formas se está viendo
también que no solamente
hay una hay un proceso diplomático de en
marcha sino también muchas cuestiones
económicas en la región y una necesidad
de regenerar económicamente Siria para
promover otra vez en las dinámicas de
acercamiento hacia un país que ha sido
clave en la estabilidad de oriente medio
y durante muchos años ahora si vemos el
panorama es muy distinto en occidente
Desde allí no hay señales de reintegrar
a Siria esta vez un panorama que nunca
vaya a cambiar
es difícil que cambie la situación de
Siria Porque
de todas formas es Siria Aunque mantiene
Un gobierno de unidad con base a las app
es un país que técnicamente está
económicamente está en quiebra y desde
el punto de vista político está
prácticamente dividida en tres sectores
está Turquía los actores de Turquía
Rusia Irán Arabia saudí son potencias
que tienen un interés manifiesto en
partes muy significativas de del
territorio no obstante me reitero hay
una necesidad por parte de esta de
Arabia saudí de reconstruir
económicamente Siria y de intentar que
Siria vuelva a tener un papel relevante
en
la región a nivel político y a nivel
económico Busca también no solamente
restaurar
económicos y restaurar la parte
económica de Siria sino también
quitarle protagonismo pretende quitarle
protagonismo a Irán
respecto de Irán además es un país que
está en un momento económico de
transición
con muy muy importante con no solamente
a nivel político sino a nivel económico
y yo creo que la la jugada de Arabia
saudí en este momento es intentar atraer
a los dos actores a la a las a una parte
con diplomática que sea y alejarle de la
parte más
negativa más por decirlo de alguna
manera
Señora González en estos últimos años
perdóneme tranquila de hecho la estamos
escuchando muy bien
usted mencionaba hace un momento lo de
la diplomacia activa Y es que en estos
últimos años hemos visto a países de
medio oriente por ejemplo
restablecer relaciones con sus vecinos
tenemos el ejemplo de Irán y Arabia
Saudita
Qatar y bahrein también estamos ante lo
que podría ser el fin de una región
polarizada en la que todo es blanco o es
negro
me gustaría decirle que sí es verdad que
la situación en Oriente medio está
cambiando que las situaciones que las
que las relaciones son muy cambiantes
las relaciones diplomáticas están
abriendo en un momento en el que parece
que el pragmatismo se está imponiendo no
obstante hay que tener mucha cautela
Porque todavía los focos de tensión son
importantes no solamente con el apoyo
del terrorismo a los grupos
proxys tenemos a jamás tenemos a la
yihad islámica tenemos a tenemos todavía
países que tienen son muy débiles desde
el punto de vista de la gobernanza pero
es un camino que está que se está
abriendo que hay un cambio de paradigma
y veremos con el tiempo como evoluciona
y en Marta González analista política y
especialista en geopolítica Muchas
gracias por acompañarnos con el análisis
aquí en directo América
Muchas gracias Un placer y así
terminamos Este primer bloque de directo
American flash 24 pero no se desconecten
porque ya regresamos con más
[Música]